let's talk about the last five years is
a musical and again you do an amazing
job you have a fantastic voice you've
been singing in so many of your of your
projects and you must it must be like a
labor of love I love it so much and this
this is like near and dear to my heart
it's about it's a very small story it's
about a marriage that's falling apart
and this music is so incredible like I
want people to experience it even if
it's a different version if it's a
version that's in your town you know on
stage like just it's so incredible the
material is outstanding and and you
should tell them a little bit about the
plot it's about you're saying it's a
relationship yeah if the the wife is
telling the story backwards and the
husband is telling the story forwards so
it's about you know so you see them
falling in love and falling out of love
and they're sort of juxtaposed and it's
like funny and heart-wrenching and
beautiful and yeah it's like just
exquisite and we had so much fun making
it it's so funny because musicals the
format's been around for so long and
what I always impresses me is that as an
audience we always go along with the
concept that people can just be talking
and then suddenly breaking a song and it
kind of makes me wish that real life was
like that I've had that where I thought
would it be great if people could just
talk and and life was like that yeah I
know why are like I wish I could live in
a musical I would yeah
well I think we both could live in a
musical I think you've got a good point
[Music]
wouldn't it be wonderful if life were
like a musical and we sang to each other
all day long yes it would be wonderful
it's like we're like a musical and
everything we said was all in wrong it
would be so fabulous if we were in a
musical we could fall in love and make
romance I just changed my mind
about this little musical I never want
to see you drop your pants I wish I wish
that I could see
maybe we should just show the clip from
your movie
yes please show the clip that would be
so groovy
[Music]
so the plan
everyone repairs after dark take a
carriage ride through Central Park but
it wouldn't be as nice as the summer in
Ohio for in sharing a room with a former
stripper and her slain
[Music]
[Applause]
is in theaters and on demand and on
iTunes Friday so check that out the
official soundtrack is available right
now Anna Kendrick thank you so much for
being yeah we'll be right back
you